[Musique]
je voudrais tout d'abord vous faire
partager une conviction de femmes je
m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes
aucune femme ne recourt de gaieté de
coeur à l'avortement il suffit d'écouter
les femmes c'est toujours un drame
[Musique]
bon
on
[Musique]
chaque 25 novembre nous sommes mobilisés
pour la journée internationale de lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
mais au-delà d'une journée au delà d'une
mobilisation au-delà d'opérations de
communication
que faisons-nous réellement pour
protéger les femmes les hommes et les
enfants victimes de violence conjugale
c'est la question je veux poser parce
que sur un sujet aussi essentiel n'avons
pas le droit de nous contenter de
slogans de parole il faut des actes et
des actes forts vous le savez depuis
plusieurs années dans notre famille
politique nous luttons pour faire en
sorte de mieux protéger les femmes et
les enfants victimes de violences nous
l'avons fait il ya quelques mois
désormais deux ans en faisant voter une
loi à l'assemblée nationale votée à
l'unanimité que j'ai l'honneur de porter
au nom du groupe l'est républicain qui a
permis d'accélérer la délivrance des
ordonnances de protection nous sommes
passés de plus de 30 jours à 6 jours et
de généraliser enfin le bracelet anti
rapprochement
ces dispositifs sont des avancées
considérables et nous avons été fiers de
porter ces mesures qui ont permis de
mieux protéger les femmes et les enfants
nous savons que notamment l'accélération
de la délivrance des ordonnances de
protection a permis de sauver la vie de
plusieurs femmes mais il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin et c'est l'appel que
je lance aujourd'hui ne nous contentons
pas de journées internationales nous
nous contentons pas de slogan et
d'illumination des bâtiments publics
faisons en sorte que nous passions des
étapes nouvelles et nécessaires
depuis l'année dernière l'explosion des
violences faites aux femmes et aux
enfants nous apporter à plus de 10% de
violence il faut désormais agir
autrement porter une vraie révolution de
la protection cette révolution elle
passera par la mise en place d'une
juridiction spécialisée en 1945 nos
prédécesseurs ont porté le juge des
enfants cette juridiction spécialisée
qui a permis de mieux protéger les
enfants il y à redire aujourd'hui mais
elle a permis une avancée à l'époque il
nous faut faire pareil pour la
protection des femmes et des enfants et
la lutte contre les violences au sein de
la famille c'est ce que les espagnols
ont fait nous ne l'avons pas encore fait
je lance à nouveau cet appel comme je lé
fais dès le lendemain du vote à
l'unanimité de notre loi passons une
nouvelle et à créer une juridiction
spécialisée et alors nous serons à la
hauteur de cet immense responsabilité
qui est celle de notre pays et de notre
société protéger les femmes les enfants
et les hommes au sein de la famille